The Joe Rogan Experience when I found
out that you wrote Friday
I was like that's insane that's
incredible yeah me and me and DJ Pooh
that's a funny [__] movie yeah yeah
it is you know I mean DJ Pooh
he's one of those he's like one of those
undercover Geniuses that
been in you've been involved in a lot of
hip-hop I mean he he helped LL do Going
Back to Cali you know I mean like he'd
been around
forever and
we're all fans of pool you know what I'm
saying and pool
um is funny he technical he he's the one
who who got rock star to do the Grand
Theft Auto Grand Theft Auto San Andreas
that whole you know like take it from
Miami and put it in LA you know I mean
take it from the Miami dope culture to
the LA gang culture so he's the one
who's behind the scenes with stuff like
that and he helped me write Friday he
produced uh it was a good day the song
um so whenever we together it's just
magic and uh we wrote Friday because we
were watching uh In Living Color
uh and we love Hollywood Shuffle by
Robert Townsend
and uh we was like let's write it let's
write a movie about the neighborhood
like because everything that was coming
out was depressing you know
colors boys in the hood right Menace to
Society right South Central it was like
yo this is a Hill Zone and we're just
like
on it did you remember it like that or
don't we laugh around here all the time
like let's let's show how it really is
for us around here and so
that's how Friday
kind of germinating became like yo we're
gonna show our version of what how we
have fun in South Central that is an
all-time classic yeah it's it's uh
it's a movie that I get commented all
more than any other like people
quoted love it yeah the the characters
are iconic
um the dress up well you know you got a
line like you got knocked the [__] out
that gets repeated
for decades yeah yeah I mean I knew I
knew it was one of those lines
because I had never heard it in a movie
before when somebody got knocked out and
I'm like
yeah this is what he gonna say when he
jump over him and look down on him like
you got knocked the [__] out how many
times you seen that on the world
yeah
how many times have you seen on a World
Star Hip-Hop now though all the time
it's just like everybody else yeah when
someone goes down it's automatic it's
automatic yeah you know all you know
that's as as an artist that's all you
want is to have a couple Classics that
people remember you for you know when
you
80 in the cafe you know drinking coffee
somebody run up and be like yo Craig
what's up yeah I mean that's that's all
you want